last friday in spain samuel was
murdered at the age of 24 they
beat him to death while they yelled at him mari
with this last victim is the horrible
realization of where
hate speech and anti fbi takes us
lgtb rights and they are human rights
[Music  ]
the discriminatory law of
the fpv community and approved by the
hungarian parliament requires a firm reaction
gates
replied
in a tweet version back to the group the
new law in hungary must be
repealed for violating human rights
and for being indecency and indecency
shame the hungarian law has no place
in europe
let's speed up the procedure
of article 7 once and for all and move forward in the
suspension of funds for
deficiencies in the rule of law
velez by cynical politicians as racist
as politics go
she has the loop
I'm coming it's facebook  be where van dyck
guardiola
is organic public asian financiers
let me send a message to all
those lgt people  maybe they
are listening to us,
we are by your side, we love you and we
defend you, never doubt your
dreams or your rights, those who
have no place are the governments that
hate and discriminate, not you and
you
[Music]